it's like my hair grew three inches in
three days I don't know how it did but
it did alright so let's do this
[Music]
the American that is a strange title
that's like calling the professional the
Italian or James Bond the Brit or
hard-boiled the Chinese assume only
singular I could find but the American
actually wasn't the anti-american
propaganda piece that people seem to
think it's gonna be it's actually the
story of a hitman slash gun craftsman
played by George Clooney then that's
pretty much it I mean yeah there is a
love story between him and this hooker
in the movie and he has to make a gun
for someone but pretty much that is it I
mean yeah the movie had a couple of
interesting parts but I had like five
pages of dialogue spread across two
hours but it mostly consisted of George
Clooney either walking or sitting or
sitting and walking or sitting in
staring just thinking about what it all
means and a couple of phone calls you
know just the regular boring stuff that
Oscar contenders are usually made of
nowadays now the parts that I did find
interesting where when it showed him
doing his craft like when he was making
a silencer out of scrap and he was
gathering parts for it that was kind of
cool and then you realize when a guy's
job is more interesting than him it's
not good
I like that professional these people
work you know all two of them that it
showed but I liked how they had to
dispose of evidence and watch their back
you know I like seeing hit men and women
work what can I say but I also like
being interested while watching it you
know it's always a little things with
movies like wanting them to entertain
you while you watch him I'll explain it
this way if I were to get a science
textbook generally speaking that
subjects in that book would be
interesting that being said it would
bore me shitless to read it for two
hours that's I can do to compare it I
mean George Clooney's character is dull
and uninteresting you start to care
where his romances going then you just
get bored I mean at a point I stopped
and realize that I have a more
interesting relationship and I'm single
the most exciting and also only chase
sequence in this movie has boring music
that plays during it for God's sakes I
mean at least make the music exciting
and then I just stopped caring
altogether when I thought I figured out
how this movie's gonna end and rest
assured when you think you know how this
movie's gonna end you do so I actually
had to come up with a new rating for
this movie which is it's oscar-worthy
and by that I mean long boring drawn-out
and dull it's a two ative fools
so I personally don't like being bored
and to interesting scenes one of which
had to do with him sitting at a table
building a silencer just wasn't enough
so just go to Starbucks and watch a
guy's sip coffee while he just sits
there in his own thoughts if that's not
your thing you might want to skip on Rip
Van hitman movie but as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more then click right here to see
more
[Music]